today I want to tell you about what's
currently my favorite number so my
favorite number changes a lot but for
now it is
288 you might be looking at that and
thinking what's special about 288 don't
worry we'll get there but first we need
to rewind a bit and talk a bit about
factorials specifically super factorials
now I know regular number file viewers
will have seen factorials before but
super factorials might be a bit new but
let's start from the basics so factorial
we'll write n factorial and it's the
product of n so n * N - 1 * and so on *
2 * 1 so it's product of N and all the
integers less than it so that the
factorial but there are other things we
can do with factorials as well so
there's something called a double
factorial and what we do here is rather
than multiplying everything we multiply
every other term so it'll be n and then
this time instead it's NT Take 2 * n
take 4 * times dot dot dot and now what
we end up with will depend on whether
n's odd or even cuz if n is even then
we'll have time 4 * 2 and if n is odd it
will be time 3 * 1 at the end so that's
double factorial but I said super
factorial so what's that well the
definition I'm going to use different
mathematicians use super factorial to
mean different things but I'm going to
say that n super factorial which is
written like this is rather than being n
* n take 1 * and so on N factorial * n
take 1 factorial time dot dot dot * 2
factorial * 1 factorial okay I'm going
to write out some of the factorials here
so 1 factorial 1 * 1 is 1 2 factorial
well that's 2 * 1 is 2 3 factorial is
going to be 3 * 2 * 1 is 6 4 factorial
is 24 5 factorial is 120 and so on now
for the super factorials one super
factorial is just one factorial so
that's one two super factorial is then 1
* 2 which is 2 3 super factorial is 6 *
2 * 1 so that's 12 4 super factorial 24
* 6 * 2 * 1 and as I'm sure you'll all
have got just as quickly as 288 and five
Super factorial is this times 120 which
I believe is
34560 so these are some values of super
factorials now I also just want to pause
side note the super factorial notation I
think it's boring we have like
exclamation marks factorials and we've
just got the letter SF so I want to
propose a few changes now some people do
write it as a dollar sign so they'll
write five doar sign I don't like this
though because you never put a dollar
sign after the number it just feels
feels wrong so so I have two different
suggestions firstly we could continue
the exclamation mark theme and use my
favorite puncturation Mark which is the
interabang so that's a question mark and
an exclamation mark and it's used for
rhetorical questions if you look at
Wikipedia the examples it gives are you
call that a hat or my favorite one of
those so that's the intera bang or I
think we fully embrace the superness and
possibly breach some copyright rules and
just go for super factorial like this um
so these are my suggestions if you have
any better suggestions of how we should
denote super factorial then let me know
the problem we often have in math is
we've exhausted all of the standard
alphabet we've exhausted all the Greek
alphabet we're running out of letters
and symbols um and especially for
something like super factorial that
isn't used as commonly um to an extent
as long as I clearly Define what I mean
by the symbols you can do what you like
the problem comes in when I've maybe not
said what this symbol means but if I'm
very clear from the start that this mean
Super factorial then we're fine um so
what can we do with the super factorials
before we move on to my favorite number
which some of you might have spot us
Elsewhere on a paper but we're going to
hold our horses there well the cool
thing is that for example if we look at
for some number K 4K super factorial
take that and we divide it by 2K
factorial we always get a square number
which I don't think is obvious but we
can we can show it cuz let's look at
this 4K super factoral that's going to
be 4K factorial * 4K - 1 factorial * 4K
- 2 factorial * 4K - 3 factorial time
and so on * 2 factorial * 1 factorial
and we can pair these up so looking at
this pair we have 4K * 4K - 1 factorial
* 4K - 1 factorial so we' we've got 4K -
1 factorial squar here and then here
okay we've got * 4K - 2 * 4K - 3
factorial squar and so on * 2 * 1
factorial squar so what we get in total
is well 4 K - 1 factorial squar * 4 K -
3 factorial SAR time dot dot dot Time 1
factorial squar so that's all these
pairs and then * 4K * 4 4K - 2 * and so
on * 2 now eiz among you will tell me
that that is 4K double factorial going
back to here and it is but I want to
leave it like this and actually here
we've got 2K terms and they're all even
so we can take out our factor of two I'm
just going to draw a square to show that
this is a square number
times Well 2 * 2K * 2 * 2K - 1 * dot dot
dot * 2 * 1 so this bit is going to be
our square number time well 2 2 K * 2K
factorial and now originally we're
looking at this divided by 2K factorial
so our little 4K super factorial divided
by 2K factorial gives us a square number
times 2 2K which is going to be a square
number because youve got a power of two
so it works a seemingly nonobvious fact
can can be shown okay now I am going to
put you out your measur and go back to
number 288 because looking at these if I
just had to glance at them I would say
that one looks the coolest we've got 3 4
5 6 Z but that's not my favorite number
this one is and it's due to one other
property of it um because not only is
288 4 factorial * 3 factorial * 2
factorial * 1 factorial it is also 4 to
^ 4+ 3 to ^ 3+ 2 to the^ 2 plus 1^ of
one and I just think that's really cool
it's the only number that this happens
for and we can kind of show this if you
want to get all technical n factorial
roughly is the < TK of 2 pi n n over e
to the N so you can think multiplying n
factorials together is going to look a
bit like multiplying n to the end
together and here we're adding n to the
end so this is obviously these are going
to grow faster than doing something like
this but anyway we don't really need to
look too much about that we just need to
look at the number 288 and appreciate
this is really cool so that's why it's
my favorite
[Music]
number this is half Seas devised by the
clever folk at brilliant it's free to
play right now over on their site and I
absolutely love it the idea is to move
one piece around until the Shaded and
non-shaded areas are exactly the same
size it's a fun test of your visual
estimation skills how good are you at
this and after a Simple Start you can
see things start getting a little bit
tricky as an Australian who spends some
time in America I particularly like this
one head over to brilliant to give it a
try the address is written there on the
screen there's also a link in the video
description and when you finish you
might be tempted to check out their
other countless courses and quizzes and
puzzles they cover all matter of Science
and Mathematics it's a great place to
give your brain a workout they have a
free 30-day trial and number file
viewers can get a 20% discount on a
subscription by going to brilliant.org
snum file again on the screen there half
sees well you can go and play that for
free right now and let me know your
score leave a comment down in the video
description I think that's a pretty good
guess for the minimum length of the
super permutation using 1 to
six
unfortunately recently someone found
found a super permutation that is
shorter in fact they found a super
permutation that had length
872 one shorter